[Music]
welcome to year in review the show where
we break down a year to bring you some
of the most notable moments in TV and
film month by month welcome to 2021
where it was in with the new but also in
with the old friends that is Warner
Brothers shook up the film industry by
releasing their entire slate of movies
on HBO Max as well as in theaters and
fans finally got the Friends reunion
they've been waiting years for could
that be any more awesome but what else
made this year so memorable and why
let's take a look in the rear view
mirror and see what we find here's your
year in review 2021 Edition
[Music]
wander and vision we are an unusual
couple you know we don't have an
anniversary
or a song
or even wedding rings well we could
rather do that
making itself seen in January was the
new series one division the first in a
string of live-action Marvel shows
popping up on Disney plus featuring
Elizabeth Olsen's Wanda maximoff and
Paul bettney's vision and set after the
events of Avengers End Game the show
Blends the style of classic sitcoms with
the MCU as the pair are living out their
ideal Suburban lives until they are
mom are you coming down soon mom our
game is freaking out
[Music]
the series was brought to the small
screen by Jack Schaefer who also had a
hand in writing Marvel's Black Widow
film released later in 2021 and despite
being a hit with critics and fans alike
the possibility of a second season of
this limited series remains as
mysterious as the show itself with many
of the actors busy working on other
Marvel projects critics say part loving
homage to TV History part off-kilter
mystery Wanda vision is a wonderfully
weird and strikingly bold step into the
small screen for the MCU and a perfect
showcase for Elizabeth Olsen and Paul
Bettany
[Music]
come on
hello
[Music]
after its World premiere at the Sundance
Film Festival in January 2020 minari
officially hit theaters in February 2021
with its eyes on the prize aka the
Oscars starring Stephen young of Walking
Dead Fame the film follows a
korean-american family who starts a farm
in 1980s Arkansas in search of their own
American dream from one of the hottest
Studios in Hollywood a24 and with Brad
Pitt serving as an executive producer
minari had plenty going for it the film
became an award show darling bringing in
six Oscar Noms including Steven young
becoming the first Asian American to be
nominated for best actor meanwhile ya
Zhang Yoon took home the film's only win
for best supporting actress critics say
led by arresting performances from
Steven young and yerry Han minari offers
an intimate and heart-wrenching portrait
of family and assimilation in 1980s
America I need everybody to repeat after
me I am
[Applause]
revolutionary Who Needs school when you
can get a dramatized history lesson in
the form of Judas in the black Messiah
Lockheed Stanfield and Daniel caluya
star in the film about FBI informant
William O'Neill who infiltrates the
Illinois Black Panther Party to keep
tabs on their charismatic leader Fred
Hampton look we oppressed your people
for a long time
and my folks grew up poor they were
sharecroppers okay hey the overseer what
if the overseer had banded with the
slaves and put the masses through
but then comrade
Judas and the black Messiah also
features stars like Jesse plemons
Dominique Fishback and Martin Sheen the
film picked up six Academy Award
nominations including one for best
picture and took home a pair for best
original song and best supporting actor
for Daniel kaluya and yes it is based on
a true story so you might learn
something but stay in school kids
critics say an electrifying
dramatization of historical events Judas
in the black Messiah is a forceful
condemnation of racial Injustice and a
major Triumph for its director and stars
[Music]
the only thing better than a legendary
mythical monster in a movie is two
legendary mythical monsters in a movie
which is what we got with Godzilla vs
Kong from cult horror director Adam
Wingard the film features Alexander
Skarsgard and stranger things Star
Millie Bobby Brown and follows King Kong
and his protectors as they embark on a
journey to find his true home but they
find themselves in the path of a very
angry Godzilla destroying his way around
the globe in true Godzilla fashion
Godzilla vs Kong was the first film in
59 years to feature both King Kong and
Godzilla and it earned over 122 million
dollars worldwide during its
International opening weekend a pretty
monstrous opening considering the
ongoing pandemic critics say delivering
squarely on its title Godzilla vs Kong
swats away character development and
human drama to deliver all the spectacle
you'd expect from giant monsters
slugging it out
even if they did kick me off the thing
still my case
even what it's like when the case gets
inside you like that
not a switch you can just turn them off
she may not be the mayor of East town
but Kate Winslet is the mayor of East
Town in the hit limited series for HBO
the oscar-winning actress plays a Small
Town Pennsylvania detective who is
investigating a murder while dealing
with her life crumbling around her she
also nailed the perfect Philadelphia
accent for the part and drank plenty of
beers while doing it Mom yeah around a
family meeting
the hell's a family meeting
all right family meeting in the dining
room okay
[Music]
Winslet was joined by a stellar
Supporting Cast headlined by Gene Smart
Evan Peters and Kate's real life good
friend Julianne Nicholson who Kate
recommended for the role and it took a
Titanic sized boat to hold the show's 16
Emmy nominations with Winslet Peters and
Nicholson each walking away as winners
critics say grounded by a career best
Kate Winslet mayor of East Town's
ambition at times exceeds its reach but
its Central mystery is supported by such
strong sense of place and character it
hardly matters
foreign
[Music]
that's quite fabulous and you've
designed this you did actually
1965 collection oh no wonder I love it
it's mine I fixed it
Cruella is a live-action prequel to The
animated Disney classic 101 Dalmatians
it said in 1970s London during the
rebellious early days of one of the most
notorious and fashionable Disney
villains audiences were anything but
cruel as they loved the outfits the
soundtrack and of course the Emma's
Stone and Thompson with stone bringing
her own special Flair to the classic
character of Cruella minus the cigarette
smoking of course critics say Cruella
can't quite answer the question of why
its Title Character needs an origin
story but this dazzling visual Feast is
awfully fun to watch whenever it's
leading ladies lock horns
Ronnie what do we got we got units
headed out there now EMS Empire
I think
[Music]
just when you thought it was safe to
make a little noise again along comes a
quiet place part two to give you a big
time swoosh John Krasinski may have been
directing once again but this time he
left most of the acting to his real and
on-screen wife Emily Blunt and the rest
of his on-screen family as they continue
to fight for their survival in silence
foreign
with a budget three times the size of
the first film this one finds the Abbott
family venturing Outside The Comfy quiet
confines of their sand Trails surrounded
home where they meet some new characters
played by Killian Murphy and jaimon
hansu and quickly learned that the
creatures that have been hunting them by
sound aren't the only threats that they
face because now they can't blink either
oh wait they can
never mind I'm totally kidding the film
loudly grabbed the biggest opening
weekend of the covid-19 pandemic to that
point and grossed nearly 300 million
dollars worldwide while also hitting the
Paramount plus streaming service 45 days
after its theatrical release you may
love this movie but remember
critics say a nerve-wracking
continuation of its predecessor a quiet
place part 2 expands the terrifying
world of the franchise without losing
track of its heart
[Music]
the electricity shot have the roof got
taken in the hurricane does the low
asking price the quick sale
[Music]
Pop's Little Dream the creator of
Hamilton lin-manuel Miranda and the
director of crazy Rich Asians John M Chu
come together for the big screen musical
in the Heights Anthony Ramos plays a
sweet natured Bodega owner with Big
Dreams saving every penny from his Daily
Grind as he imagines and sings about a
better life if this doesn't make you
want to sing your way down the street
next time you take a walk what will
critics say lights up for in the Heights
a joyous celebration of Heritage
Community fueled by dazzling Direction
and sing-along songs
foreign
coming in Fast and Furious 2 I suppose
is the pure definition of a summer
blockbuster F9 the fast Saga released
almost exactly 20 years after the first
film in the franchise and yeah that's a
lot of fast cars franchise regular
Justin Lin returned to the director's
chair for a fifth time to do F9 which
finds Dom Toretto leading a quiet life
Off the Grid with Letty and his son
Little Brian ah but of course danger
lurks just over the peaceful Horizon and
he eventually finds himself back with
the crew looking to stop the most
skilled assassin and Driver they've ever
encountered and oh yeah he just happens
to be Dom and Mia's estranged brother
Jacob played by John Cena
yeah
sending a new pickup location
the film grossed over 720 million
dollars at the worldwide box office and
set the stage for a sequel to be
released in 2023 which could possibly be
the end to the Saga but come on do we
really believe that critics say F9 sends
the franchise hurtling further over the
top than ever but director Justin Lynn's
knack for Preposterous set pieces keeps
the action humming hey we did that whole
part without saying family
foreign
sucks
[Applause]
after three new Marvel series that hit
Disney Plus in 2021 kicked things off
Black Widow became the first film in
phase four of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it was directed by Kate
shortland and her first foray into
superhero films isn't that super
Scarlett Johansson returns as Natasha
Romanov AKA Black Widow for an official
eighth time as the character is faced
with a dangerous conspiracy and forced
to confront her past relationships and
history as a spy from before she became
an Avenger I want to say something right
off the bat you haven't dated
just as beautiful and disciples that
they stitched our marriage
you got fat
still good Scarlett got some help in
this high flying flick from Florence Pew
Rachel Vice and David Harbor as Red
Guardian the Russian super soldier
counterpart to Captain America and a
father figure to Natasha what a cool dad
the film was delayed three times from an
original May 2020 release due to the
covid-19 pandemic but it seemed to be
worth the wait for audiences Who Loved
getting a little character development
mixed in with all the Blockbuster Marvel
action critics say black widow's deeper
themes are drowned out in all the action
but it remains a solidly entertaining
Standalone Adventure that's rounded out
by a stellar Supporting Cast
me this this is a real
you don't understand did you okay I I
will show you that okay
Candyman no Candyman coming in August
was the horror flick Candy Man bet you
can't say that five times fast into a
mirror no wait don't do it the film is a
direct sequel to the 1992 film of the
same name and stars Yahya Abdul Mateen
II and tiona Paris returning to the now
gentrified Chicago neighborhood where
the legend began the film also features
Vanessa Williams Virginia Madsen and
Tony Todd reprising their roles from the
original film
foreign
horror filmmaking All-Star Jordan peel
was a co-writer for Candyman along with
when Rosenfeld and director Nia DeCosta
who's Now set to direct another sequel
2023's the Marvels and it's gonna be
marvelous right it's all right I just
had to critics say Candyman takes an
incisive visually thrilling approach to
deepening the franchise's mythology and
terrifying audiences along the way
thank you
the second Marvel film of the year and
of phase four in the MCU was Xiang Chi
and the legend of the ten Rings starring
simulio as Shang Chi alongside stars
like Aquafina Tony Leong Benedict Wong
Michelle yo and Ben Kingsley sorry sir
Ben Kingsley in the film Shang Chi and
his sister are drawn into the web of the
mysterious 10 Rings organization by
their father who is also the leader talk
about family drama you okay
come on
[Music]
as the first Marvel film with an Asian
lead and director and predominantly
Asian cast fans loved seeing the
franchise covering new cultural ground
while keeping the same action comedy and
emotion they've come to expect critics
say Xiang Chi and the legend of the ten
Rings isn't entirely free of Marvel's
familiar formula but this exciting
origin story expands on the MCU in more
ways than one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hit of the year was undoubtedly the
Netflix series squid game where hundreds
of cash-strapped contestants compete for
a big prize by playing children's games
but with deadly Stakes so yeah
definitely not a kid's show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the project was being shopped around for
nearly a decade before it finally got
some interest from Netflix and
considering Bloomberg reported that the
series had brought in nearly a billion
dollars worth of publicity to the
streaming giant yeah with a B there's
probably plenty of people out there
kicking themselves for not getting in on
all the fun and games critics say squid
games unflinching brutality is not for
the faint of heart but sharp social
commentary and a surprisingly tender
core will keep viewers glued to the
screen even if it's while watching
between their fingers
foreign
so you're gonna have to do the right
thing for a change
go take your tiny hands off of me along
with the usual Halloween Shenanigans
October also brought us Carnage as in
venom Let There Be Carnage it's the
second film in Sony Spider-Man universe
and the sequel to 2018's Venom with Andy
Circus serving as director Tom Hardy is
once again Eddie Brock still struggling
to coexist with the shape-shifting
Extraterrestrial Venom but they're
forced to put their differences aside to
take on the film's big Baddie Cletus
Cassidy played by Woody Harrelson but
I'm the only person that took you in
when when your friends kicked you off
the planet Ming Mong because you are a
reject you are a pariah lethal
protection my ass you couldn't protect
anything you are useless you can get a
job down here cleaning toilets
audiences love the abundance of the
action fun fight scenes and all the
comedy but most importantly the can't
miss post-credit surprise is where all
the buzz is don't miss it critics say a
sequel aimed squarely at fans of the
original's Odd Couple chemistry Venom
Let There Be Carnage eagerly Embraces
the franchise's sillier side can I trust
you with something I've been having
dreams about a girl
fallen in battle
felt like a vision
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake and
coming in hot in October as in the
desert planet of Iraq is hot was the
much anticipated Dune directed by Denise
Villeneuve did that rhyme and doing
their best not to get sand in their
shoes was the Epic ensemble cast that
includes
timate Charlemagne Rebecca Ferguson
Oscar Isaac Josh Brolin stellen
Skarsgard Dave Batista Zendaya David
dasmacci and Jason Momoa and Javier
Bardem
Emperor asks us to bring peace to Iraqis
House of Trades except this marks the
third adaptation of Frank Herbert's 1965
novel following David Lynch's 1994 film
and John Harrison's miniseries from the
year 2000. fans and critics have been
digging this version of June and good
news for them because the film primarily
only covers the first half of the book
and a second part is planned for a 2023
release gosh doing it that sounds great
ah the dads out there will like that one
critics say Dune occasionally struggles
with its unwieldy Source material but
those issues are largely overshadowed by
the scope and ambition of this visually
thrilling adaptation
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Marvel fans were eternally grateful for
a third Marvel film in 2021 and it came
in the form of
eternals the film brings a new team of
superheroes to the MCU a group of
Ancient Aliens who have been living on
Earth for thousands of years emerging
from the Shadows after the event of
Avengers end game to reunite against
Mankind's most ancient enemy the
deviants yikes they don't sound good at
all you guys are gonna love the next
scene I come in on a wire because you
know I can't fly wait are we getting
back together we need to talk the
deviants are back
I don't know how many there are the
film's ensemble cast includes Angelina
Jolie Salma Hayek kit Harrington Gemma
Chan Richard Madden Camille nanjiani
Leah McHugh Brian Tyree Henry Lauren
ridloff Don Lee and Harris Patel yes
it's a lot of names but the film also
has a lot of action so it totally
balances out critics say an ambitious
superhero epic that soars as often as it
strains eternals takes the MCU in
intriguing and occasionally confounding
new directions
[Music]
started getting some visitors
from every universe
hello Peter movie fans received the gift
of two of the most highly anticipated
films of the past few years in December
of 2021 starting with Spider-Man no way
home the sequel to Spider-Man's
homecoming and far from home because
home is where the title is apparently
and while everybody loves Spider-Man I
mean except for maybe Jay Jonah Jameson
the real excitement for this movie was
due to villains from the past films and
past universes making their way into
this world I'm sorry what was your name
again Dr Otto Octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name that includes Willem dafoe's Green
Goblin and Alfred Molina's Doctor
Octopus with his identity unmasked Peter
Parker turns to Doctor Strange for help
but they end up breaking open the
Multiverse and allowing in plenty of
unwanted guests which usually happens
when we try to throw a pizza party in
the office audiences got caught up in
Spider-Man's box office web with a
monster debut making it the third
biggest opening weekend ever the film
grossed a whopping 253 million opening
weekend more in three and a half days
than any other film released in 2021 and
at the time of this recording the film
is certified fresh with a 94 on the
Tomato Meter critics say a bigger Bolder
Spider-Man sequel no way home expands
the franchise's scope and Stakes without
losing sight of its humor and heart
you seem particularly triggered right
now can you tell me what happened
I've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am I crazy
we don't use that word in here and
finally fans were delighted at the
chance to once again ingest a strange
pill after the Matrix resurrections
became the fourth installment in The
Matrix film franchise coming 18 years
after the previous film Keanu Reeves
Carrie Anne moss and Jada Pinkett Smith
reprized their roles from previous films
in the series and they're joined by
Yahya Abdul Mateen II Jessica henwick
Jonathan Groff Neil Patrick Harris
Priyanka Chopra Jonas and Christina
Ricci whoa
[Music]
is
when she's 10 feet it happens when they
after directing the first three Matrix
movies alongside her sister Lily Lana
Wachowski went at this one by herself
also producing and co-writing the film
which finds Neo back inside the Matrix
after his life takes an unexpected turn
to say the least and there you have it
our highlights from a year of bounce
back non-traditional Blockbuster
entertainment as always we couldn't go
over every notable release from such a
big year but go easy on us it was a
tough one